so I'm not really I'm feeling my wall
today I can't talk in front of it so I'm
gonna talk in front of my train tickets
I don't know how many train tickets I
have right I have a lot of train tickets
I used to have some pretty awful like
horrible contorting mirrors on this wall
one day I just decided hey I'm gonna
take those down but when I took them
down I notice there were loads of little
holes in the wall so to cover up those
holes I put train tickets everywhere so
later on today I'm going to London on
the train obviously but right now I've
got a few hours to spare I'm not really
doing anything I'm a bit bored I've got
some things I'd like to tell you so
we're gonna do a little vlog obviously I
don't know if you're the kind of person
that's interested in my life you might
just be the kind of person that likes to
watch me do stupid things like paint
myself purple and drink ketchup and all
that crazy crumbs crazy crumbs crazy
crumbs I can't talk but if you are
interested in my world the Charli verse
listen on and we will travel them on the
train to the Charli verse together as
one okay let's go so in the last video
that I posted on this channel I talked
about my album of music that I've made
with my musical band chameleon circuit
and our band plays a very Beach style of
music we played trunk Time Lord Rock or
songs about the TV show Doctor Who and
they have this which is the official
Doctor Who Magazine and recently me and
my band were interviewed you see that
their truck we were interviewed by this
guy called Benjamin cook who is one of
the writers for Doctor Who Magazine and
if you live in the UK and you spot this
magazine anywhere and you open it up to
the inside back page obviously they had
to use the picture of the purple man but
I don't blame them for that
and I think they've chosen the best
quote I love it I love it so much
speaking of chameleon circuit something
insanely cool happened recently about a
day or so after I posted my video about
chameleon circuit
I got a few messages on Twitter from
people telling me to look at the rock
album chants on iTunes and lo and behold
I don't know what lo and behold means
what I'm gonna use anyway lo and behold
um my album what is number 37 on the
rock albums on iTunes which means that
my band right my band that plays songs
about friggin doctor who has a top 40
selling rock album on iTunes it was like
u2 Arctic Monkeys Keane and then
chameleon circus
in circuits so I just want to say thank
you to everybody who's bought the album
this is something that I've never
anticipated it is so cool so thank you
so much something else that is really
weird and cool and that I didn't expect
happened recently I'm gonna tell you
about that as well there is this thing
that some website is doing where you can
vote for mr. Twitter UK and the first
time I heard about this I had a little
look and I saw that I was on page eleven
or something and I had about 20 votes
and I was like oh that's cool some
people actually voted for me that's a
bit weird and yesterday I posted a tweet
about this saying look at this mr.
Twitter UK and then people started
voting for me and then more people
started voting for me and now right I'm
number 5 on this wall of the top mr.
Twitter UK people right now for some
reason people seem to think that I am
more worthy of mr. Twitter UK than
Daniel Radcliffe the guy who plays
friggin Harry Potter and Stephen Fry
Stephen Fry love Stephen Fry Alan Carr
Jimmy Carr Russell Brand all of these
people and for some reason below me in
this thing if you want to have a look
then I'll put a link in the sidebar
don't feel that you have to vote for me
I don't think I deserve any more votes
on this thing but that is well cool
apparently if you win
then you get put on a wall somewhere and
I have always wanted to be on a wall
I've probably rambled on long enough
about my life and things that are
happening so I'm gonna go I will say
obviously that even though this video
was just a blog and I know some people
don't like vlogs I mean I get comments
all the time on my videos saying why
don't you do some vlogs and then
whenever I do a vlog people are like
what is this I don't understand stop
doing these but I've been really
focusing on brainstorming video ideas
recently I've got about three really
good ones in the works which will be
approaching in the next coming weeks but
for now goodbye um one thing my hair is
getting a bit long so I'm probably gonna
get a haircut I know the idea of me
getting a haircut for a lot of people is
quite scary but it's gonna happen so put
up with it ye